Yeah,
awhile ago I stumbled upon this poem by
Charles Bukowski on what it takes to be
a writer.
If it doesn't come bursting out of you
in spite of everything,
don't do it as it comes out of your
heart and your mind and your mouth and
your gut.
Don't do it.
If you have to sit up for hours staring
at your computer screen or hunched over
your typewriter,
searching the words,
don't do it.
If it's hard work,
just thinking about doing it.
Don't do it unless it comes out of your
soul like a rugged,
unless being still would drive you to
madness or suicide or murder known.
Do it when it is truly time.
If you have been chosen,
it will do it.
I itself and then it will keep on doing
it until you die or it dies in you.
There is no other way and never was.
His message of course extends to other
creative professions from directing to
composing music to painting or even
sports and although I think it's a
beautiful poem and quite a romantic way
of looking at creative endeavors.
He's also horribly and sentimentally
wrong.
History is filled with creative geniuses
were it didn't just came bursting out of
them.
Take some of our current superintendent
riders,
for example,
from Aaron Sorkin who describes having a
perpetual writer's block to George r
Martin,
who can't seem to finish his new book to
Terentino's,
who has spoken about how difficult it is
to be staring at an empty piece of paper
where somehow his new movie needs Sapir
and finally Robert Mckee,
writer of the Bible and screenwriting,
who claims he is the biggest
procrastinator in the world.
I think for these creative minds,
birth asa for you,
me and many others,
the more excited you are about your
creative endeavor,
the bigger the project,
and to more important to fulfilling your
dreams,
the harder it is to actually sit down
and do it.
The trap that many writers,
including myself,
fall into mainly consists of staring
motionless at a blank page.
It's not that we don't want to write or
that we don't have the ability to put
words down on the page.
We just don't have any good ideas.
It's not a fun place to be.
Believe me,
Steven Pressfield states there was a
secret that real writers know that want
to be writer,
stones it.
It's not the writing part that's hard.
What's hard is sitting down to write and
he calls this force that keeps us from
sitting down.
Resistance.
Resistance according to Pressfield,
is what stands the life we live and are
in lifts.
Life stands between us enter dreams or
for we want to become and what we want
to create.
Are you a writer that doesn't write?
A painter,
doesn't paint an entrepreneur that never
starts adventure,
then you have fallen victim to
resistance.
Resistance is to be taken seriously,
says pressfield's.
It has to be declared evil.
Millions have been defeated by it.
Dreams of diets because one gave up or
never dare to starts.
It is therefore essential to learn to
recognize resistance and learn how to
beat it.
Pressfield gives a beautiful description
of resistance.
He states that resistance is invisible
and internal.
We might think that it is friends,
jobs,
bets,
or the Internet that keeps us from our
creative work.
Birth that's false.
Hungry.
I should get coffee.
Coffee would help me think pressure,
right,
something purse,
then reward myself with coffee,
coffee,
and a muffin.
Okay,
so I need to establish the scenes
maybe been not good enough.
The force of resistance,
stent thrombosis to engage with these
things and procrastinates comes from
ourselves.
Resistance is to self generate enemy
from within.
Resistance is most commonly expressed in
procrastination because it is the
easiest to rationalize our starts bit.
I'll start tomorrow.
There was one week when you wore
sweatpants.
Of course.
Resistant school is to have a seeing
this until our deathbeds.
Other manifestations of resistance can
be indulging in alcohol,
sex Mr Batian,
TV,
gossip and eating fat,
sugar,
salt and chocolate.
Prestfield describes that indulging is
not always a manifestation of
resistance,
but if fuel,
hello and unfulfilled afterwards,
it's probably was.
We subconsciously know that we gave up
our longterm goal for instant
gratification.
Resistance Speedos?
Yeah.
Out there.
Sticking your Dick in anything that
moves.
I'm trying to get back at me,
which is fine.
Do you know what the worst thing is?
You're not writing.
You have this gift.
You have this incredible talent and
you're just flushing it down.
The toilet resistance
expresses itself when you create drama
in your life,
claim victim hood when you spent your
time criticizing others,
when you turn your life into a soap or
when you rationalize a way while you
haven't started yet as a working artist
doesn't accept this kind of self
destructive behavior in his life because
it prevents him from his work.
Yet resistance can be helpful.
Resistance points us to our true
calling.
It's can be felt when we fear starting a
creative project.
Does fear mean stead?
It is something that we need to do
something we have a deep love for.
If she didn't love project,
that's terrifying you.
You wouldn't feel anything at all.
You want to step on the wire.
I don't know if I'll be able to take
to do.
The more resistance you feel towards the
project,
the more fulfilled you will be when you
finish it.
Resistance always points us to our true
north,
so how do we consistently beat
resistance as Steven Pressfield,
ses by turning pro as he describes
tuning pro,
it has nothing to do with making or nuts
making money out of your creative work.
It isn't perfect.
If philosophy of work in ideology of
ethics on how you conduct your creative
projects,
you can turn professional one day and
being immature again.
The next
in short,
I was back.
Yes,
yes,
there is something I want to ask you.
How the fuck do you write?
So many books so fast
I think.
Oh,
I've had a really good six months.
I've written three chapters that you've
got three books in that time.
The way that.
The way that I work,
I try to get out there and I try to get
six pages a day,
so with a book like end of watch and I
work when I'm working,
I work every day,
three,
four hours and I try to get those six
pages and I try to get them fairly clean
and you do hit six pages a day.
I usually do.
Now death is an example of a pro as
pressfield states to professional knows
that the mundane physical act of sitting
down and starting to work sets in
motion,
a mysterious process that produces
inspiration.
The immature waits for inspiration.
The professional knows that it will come
off to you.
Starts now,
as you see,
turning pro has little to do with
talens.
George Rr Martin is one of the most
gifted authors of generation bits.
He hasn't turned pro,
which is why I am still waiting for a
next book.
The professional therefore x in the face
of fear when the amateur fierce,
a big creative endeavor.
He waits for the fear to disappear.
The professional knows this will never
happen and starts anyway,
and immature dreams of stardom and
glory.
The professional has no use for this.
He knows that success is merely a
byproduct of work.
He does the work and let's do rewards
come or not come as they may.
By doing this pro four,
it's disappointment and Nia offer
assistance that it will use to make us
give up.
Are you now or have you ever been a
member of the Communist Party?
May I introduce to evidence you are out
of order my work?
No,
no,
no.
I will.
No.
I'm making this determination.
The chair will rule critical just a
minute.
Your screenplays for too long.
I've heard that before.
The professional
also place it as it lays.
He doesn't find excuses in bed.
Luck at food,
city or injustice needed us.
He led a windfall or good luck for him
into thinking he is there already.
I'll write you a movie for $1,200 and
you don't want your name on it.
No,
you don't want my name.
He accepts the situation as it is the
pro marching song.
No matter what the professional,
let's go his ego.
He doesn't take failure or success
personally.
Fear of rejection is human and lies deep
in everyone.
Resistance,
no stis and uses it to paralyze us and
prevent us from doing our work.
Prestfield states that this is one of
the hardest aspects of turning pro.
The professional puts his heart and soul
into his work.
Then he steps back and assesses the.
It's hardly at courtly.
He takes notes where he can do better.
His next project,
and then he moves on the professional.
This accepts criticism,
but it's never takes it personally.
He knows resistance will use rejection
to break him.
Therefore,
the professional and jurors adversity
when he's faced down in arena chewing on
sand and everyone's laughing at him,
he knows it is still better to be in the
arena than standing on the sideline.
Lastly,
where the amateur might make romantic
claims about doing it for the love about
not caring or being even proud of not
making money.
The professional recognizes that too
much love,
we'll freeze him.
Playing for money is to device he uses
to adopt a working men modality.
As pressfield states the muse of
inspiration,
loss of blue collar work ethic.
She lost a working stiff and hates prima
donnas.
The pro takes money to turn his life
into his job,
technically place bay,
but in the end he does it for the love
of the game.
At this point,
you might be thinking,
well,
the cold and heartless way to look at
creative work.
Where's the romance?
Where stem mythology to beauty and
mystery of ours.
These are things that we aim for when we
turn pro because we know when we beat
resistance and sit down to do our work,
something magical happens when we sit
down and grind it out.
Inspiration strikes,
it starts to flow effortlessly.
Color the flow states call it being in
the zone or espresso fueled does call it
abuse where resistance recites and hell
creation has a seat in heaven.
Here the Mucus looks down and my issue
grades your professionalism.
When you present yourself to her with an
attitude of legalist,
snus and surface,
she will come down and sit on your
shoulder,
a powerful ally to help you in your
endeavor.
When we beat resistance and starts,
the Muse will guide us battling the dark
force of resistance beside us till we
finish our project.
It is only at this moment when you type
that last word,
when you played that last note,
when you danced,
that last step that you can look
resistance in the eye and say,
rest in peace motherfucker.
After which she will start a new project
and the battle starts a new
thanks for watching everyone in the day
or two.
I will drop an extra video for our
patrons where I will talk about other
aspects of turning pro.
Uh,
if you want to support us,
you can find the link in the
description,
follow followers on facebook for updates
and extra us and we'll see you next
week.